when I die I would like for my body to
be laid out to be eaten by animals
having your body laid out to be eaten by
animals is not for everyone maybe you
have already had the end-of-life talk
with your family and decided on I don't
know
cremation and in the interest of full
disclosure what I am proposing for my
dead body is not strictly legal at the
moment but it's not without precedent
we've been laying out our dead for all
of human history
it's called exposure burial in fact it's
likely happening right now as we speak
in the mountainous regions of Tibet they
practice sky burial a ritual where the
body is left to be consumed by vultures
in Mumbai in India they put there those
who follow the Parsee religion put their
dead in structures called towers of
silence these are interesting cultural
tidbits but they just haven't really
been that popular in the Western world
they're not what you'd expect in America
our guest traditions have come to be
chemical and boming followed by burial
at your local cemetery or more recently
cremation I myself am a recent
vegetarian which means I spent the first
30 years or so of my life
frantically inhaling animals as many as
I could get my hands on why when I die
should they not have their turn with me
am I not an animal biologically speaking
are we not all in this room animals
accepting the fact that we are animals
have some potentially terrifying
consequences it means accepting that we
are doomed to decay and die just like
any other creature on earth for the last
nine years I've worked in the funeral in
first as a Crematory operator then as a
mortician and most recently it's the
owner of my own funeral home and I have
some good news if you're looking to
avoid the whole doomed to decay and die
thing you will have all the help in the
world in that avoidance from the funeral
industry it's a multi-billion dollar
industry and its economic model is based
on the principle of protection
sanitation and beautification of the
corpse whether they mean to or not the
funeral industry promotes this idea of
human exceptionalism doesn't matter what
it takes how much it costs how bad it is
for the environment we're going to do it
because humans are worth it it ignores
the fact that deaths can be in an
emotionally messy and complex affair and
that there is beauty in decay beauty in
the natural return to the earth from
whence we came now I don't want you to
get me wrong I absolutely understand the
importance of ritual especially when it
comes to the people that we love but we
have to be able to create and practice
this ritual without harming the
environment which is why we need new
options so let's return to the idea of
protection sanitation and beautification
we'll start with a dead body the funeral
industry will protect your dead body by
offering to sell your family a caskets
made of hardwood or metal with a rubber
sealant at the cemetery on the day of
burial that casket will be lowered into
a large concrete or metal vault
we're wasting all of these resources
concrete's metal hardwoods hiding them
in vast underground fortresses when you
choose burial at the cemetery your dead
body is not coming anywhere near the
dirt that surrounds it food for worms
you are not next to the industry will
sanitize your body
through embalming the chemical
preservation of the dead
this procedure drains your blood and
replaces it with a toxic cancer-causing
formaldehyde they say they do this for
the public health because the dead body
can be dangerous but the doctors in this
room will tell you that that claim would
only apply if the person had died of
some wildly infectious disease like
Ebola even human decomposition which
let's be honest is a little stinky and
unpleasant is perfectly safe the
bacteria that causes disease is not the
same bacteria that causes decomposition
finally the industry will beautify the
corpse they'll tell you that the natural
dead body of your mother or father is
not good enough as it is they'll put it
in makeup they'll put it in a suit
they'll inject dyes so the person looks
a little more alive just resting
embalming is a cheat code providing the
illusion that death and then decay are
not the natural end for all organic life
on this planet now if this system of
beautification sanitation and protection
doesn't appeal to you you are not alone
there is a whole wave of people funeral
directors designers environmentalists
trying to come up with a more
eco-friendly way of death for these
people death is not necessarily a
pristine makeup powder blue tuxedo kind
of affair there's no question that our
current methods of death are not
particularly sustainable what with the
waste of resources and our reliance on
chemicals even cremation which is
usually considered the environmentally
friendly option uses per cremation the
natural gas equivalent of a 500-mile car
trip so where do we go from here last
summer I was in the mountains of North
Carolina hauling buckets
of woodchips in the summer Sun I was at
Western Carolina University at their
body farm more accurately called a human
decomposition facility bodies donated to
science are brought here and their decay
is studied to benefit the future of
forensics on this particular day there
were twelve bodies laid out in various
stages of decomposition one some were
skeletonized one was wearing purple
pajamas one still had blond facial hair
visible the forensic aspect is really
fascinating but not actually why I was
there I was there because a colleague of
mine named Katrina Spade is attempting
to create a system not of cremating the
dead but composting the dead
she calls the system recomposition and
we've been doing it with cattle and
other livestock for years she imagines a
facility where the family could come and
lay their dead loved one in a
nutrient-rich mixture that would in four
to six weeks reduce the body bones and
all to soil in those four to six weeks
your molecules become other molecules
you literally transform how would this
fit in with the very recent desire a lot
of people seem to have to be buried
under a tree or to become a tree when
they die in a traditional cremation the
ashes that are left over inorganic bone
fragments form a thick chalky layer that
unless distributed in the soil just
right can actually hurt or kill the tree
but if your recomposed
if you actually become the soil you can
nourish the tree and become the
postmortem contributor you've always
wanted to be that you deserve to be so
that's one option for the future of
cremation but what about the future of
cemeteries there are a lot of people who
think that we shouldn't even have
cemeteries anymore because we're running
out of land but what if we reframed it
and the corpse wasn't the lands enemy
but its potential Savior I'm talking
about conservation
eriell where large swaths of land are
purchased by a land trust the beauty of
this is that once you plant a few dead
bodies in that land it can't be touched
it can't be developed on hence the term
conservation burial it's the equivalent
of chaining yourself to a tree
postmortem
hell no I won't go no really I can't I'm
decomposing under here any money that
the family gives to the cemetery would
go back into protecting and managing the
land there are no headstones and and no
graves in the typical sense the graves
are scattered about the property under
elegant mounds marked only by a rock or
a small metal disc or sometimes only
locatable by GPS there's no embalming no
heavy metal caskets my funeral home
sells a few caskets made out of things
like woven willow and bamboo but
honestly most of our families just
choose a simple shroud there are none of
the big vaults that most cemeteries
require just because it makes it easier
for them to landscape families can come
here they can look Cherie ate in nature
they can even plant a tree or a shrub
though only native plants to the area
are allowed the dead then blend
seamlessly in with the landscape there's
hope in conservation cemeteries they
offer dedicated green space in both
urban and rural areas they offer a
chance to reintroduce native plants and
animals to a region they offer public
trails places for spiritual practice
places for classes and events places
where nature and mourning meet most
importantly they offer us once again a
chance to just decompose in a hole in
the ground the soil let me tell you has
missed us I think for a lot of people
they're starting to get the sense that
our current funeral industry isn't
really working for them for many of us
being sanitized and beautified just
doesn't reflect us it doesn't reflect
what we stood for during our lives while
changing the way we bury our dead solve
climate change no but it will make bold
moves and how we see ourselves as
citizens of this planet if we can die in
a way that is more humble and self-aware
I believe that we stand a chance thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]